definitely I think it's it's interesting
time I think it's definitely revealing a
lot of things about different cultures
and you know I n even some of the
practices right I think you know we're
we're very you know what we you and I
were both huggers right we're all for
syrup I think we're all very well aware
of some of our interpersonal like habits
now oh yeah dude like how much of an
affectionate hugger I am it's really
that I'm not to hug random strangers in
the supermarket and [ __ ] like you trying
to get somebody's I'm trying to like
sell it like it's drugs and [ __ ] like
yogi trying to get somebody's hug real
quick let me be behind Saddlebrook let
me see what's up and you know what I
realized too that I have to be very very
like mindful and conscious about and a
lot of people have been asking me to
talk about this situation specifically
when it comes to like you know a lot of
hate that of you know Asian Americans
I've been getting and the reason why I
haven't done a podcast on that yet and I
think I am going to start doing podcasts
about it and I'm gonna start calling it
the whole segment just gonna be called
coffee while Asian the reason why is
because I want to be very careful about
how what I say and how I feel about
things right because I don't want to
come off as somebody who is just getting
caught up in whatever the media says and
and sometimes like when I see the plight
of somebody who looks like me and what
they're going through and I start
putting myself in their place I start
getting [ __ ] angry right and I have
to be very careful with that voice
sometimes because I could get on the
other side and just start mowing people
down because you know just for an
example you know I've been walking
around I walk around in this area called
South Pasadena South pasture thought you
went jogging there it's nice it's fun
super first everybody waves it says hi
to you just it's just really dope and
but ever since the Copa situation I've
had so far three instances where people
treated me like [ __ ] and has never
happened before like and really um I
have never I've never had that [ __ ]
happen to me you know specifically in
South Pasadena like for example we were
I was at UM la Monica I think I took you
there's that it's the air and coffee
shop right right you know and I told and
I'm not told you this but it was it was
that lady who
said you people to me and she was like
Michigan is happening because of you
people now my dish you might have said
like people who are social distancing
but ever a good idea to say
entertainment just PSA for everybody
listening never a good phrase yeah don't
lead with your people you know because
of you people and I heard that [ __ ] and
I was like you know what you might have
met people who aren't social distancing
however
I take it like that and you know lost
story short with this I'm not gonna go
I'll tell the whole story in another
podcast but you know the manager stepped
in and she kind of kicked her out and I
had to sit there and I was like yo I've
been living in this nice like Pasadena
super diverse area for the longest
[ __ ] time right there I've been here
for about six [ __ ] years never had a
single instance where somebody saying
you people at me or looked at me like I
was an outsider never ever had that
[ __ ] experience before yeah and then
and this is what we're talking about
when we talk about the rhetoric
especially specifically coming from the
President of the United States
when he says a phrase like China virus
right right and people don't understand
how how powerful those words are how
gives a green light to other people who
have already had these these bigoted
feelings towards a culture right and
they never really felt the strength or
the power to safe because it's been in
their [ __ ] mind for a long [ __ ]
time but when the president gives you
strength to say that that's when you
have an instance like me where I've been
in South Pasadena for six years one of
the most diverse nicest places I've ever
been and somebody looks at me at the
coffee shop that I go to on a daily
basis this is because of you people
and I sat there and you know at first I
kind of laughed about it with you know
as a comic I wrote a whole sketch about
it but then afterwards I'm like hey [ __ ]
this [ __ ] [ __ ] you you know and I was
like yo [ __ ] slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of you right and it kind of opened up
this whole conversation and especially
for a lot of asian-americans for you to
really think about this and not and I
talked about this to my best friend he's
sitting across from me right now on this
video conference he's he's an
african-american male right I grew up in
a very diverse area black community
Asian community right so you know the I
call it you know the the black American
plight is not something that's foreign
to me right I've seen it with my own
eyes like I've seen disparity I've seen
this [ __ ] my whole life so when people
talk about black American issues I
tend to feel a certain way about it
because I grew up around this community
right like we were around each other my
whole life and so sometimes I think the
one positive thing that came out from
this is that there I know there are
maybe a handful of asian-americans that
see this and they saw when the whole
Trayvon Martin thing came out right all
right and for other people to like in my
asian-american community when you saw
this black lives matter movement and I'm
not I'm not saying that a lot of people
that I know didn't believe in that [ __ ]
but there are were a handful of it right
but that moment I heard that you people
even though I understood what that you
people phrase was said when it was said
to another culture like the black
American culture when it was said to me
I was like it clicked even harder it's
like how [ __ ] bury you know like what
did I do
who what what did I do you know and it
kind of made me sit there I was a little
frustrated with it I was like oh so this
is this is what this is what the black
American community is talking about
right now and you never really know and
then the the feud a few weeks after that
when I was walking this this old lady
she had a little [ __ ] rake and she
was like I don't see you wearing a mess
make sure that you stay away from me and
I was like hold on a second
and so I was like okay I wasn't wearing
my mess when I was walking but I was
clearly like 12 feet 15 feet away from
her right and I started walking by and I
saw this other white couple going by
they weren't wearing any masks they were
right next to when she goes good morning
how am i oh okay so this is [ __ ]
interesting and I wanted to sit there
and I'm like damn this doesn't and it
got to a point where I saw it
repetitively right so there was other
time where this guy was walking a little
too close to me and it was kind of like
being an [ __ ] about it and I already
cursed somebody out diary curse that
lady out in the in the coffee shop I
already had it and now I start to
realize where sometimes you all you all
you can do is roll your [ __ ] eyes and
you get fed up with the [ __ ] it's like
what am I supposed to do now am I gonna
suck everybody that comes my [ __ ] way
you know you get tired tired of this
[ __ ]
yeah you know it's it's hard man I think
reminds me what is it Martin Luther King
quote like injustice anywhere is a
threat to justice everywhere yeah right
you know and it's and you like to think
that we're in the year 2020 and
the you know we're in California it's
one of the very progressive you know
blue states but you know we're also a
state that imprisoned a large part
portion of our Japanese population
you know after Pearl Harbor you know I
mean and you like to think that these
knee-jerk reactions of stereotyping and
and and and hate what would happened but
no it's they happen and they've been
happening here they've been happening
globally what is the black people in
China to we're like getting like you
know turned away from McDonald's and
apparently that was like I was like that
is Wow anyways it's you know and this
these things where you think you have to
be right like I don't know like these
things happen but I think it's we have
to like join together and stand up for
each other and and make sure that when
you know we all we all are dealing with
a very like present threat but it
doesn't mean that we lose some of that
camaraderie between groups and and and
and and just being an ally you know if
it's not your group it's not your person
it's being like hey no that's that's
messed up like yeah then I was and I
have to not get caught up in that [ __ ]
because I also have to mention too on
these walks so there are the yeah I
could tell like some of these white
people they're like super sensitive to
the situation they look me in the eye
they're like good morning like hey
you're safe with us and and I gotta say
that even though I'm talking about three
situations where that negative thing
happened there was still about ninety or
a hundred more situations where there
was a white person that came up and they
said good morning to me they said hello
they smiled at me so I got to make sure
and I want and the reason why I'm
bringing back is hoping a be careful
about what I talk about when it comes to
these situations I can't let three
[ __ ] [ __ ] represent the other 99%
of the people that I met that day right
and that's the hard part right I think
that's a hard part for a lot of people
you see stuff in media you you you have
these bad instances with a specific
culture but you have to look at the I
look at the numbers it's like listen if
that's three people out of like
100 or 200 people that I saw in the last
week then Who am I to go here and judge
this whole group of people from these 1
from these few individuals who made that
mistake right but it doesn't make you
want to sock him in the [ __ ] face my
god I just wanted to just walk I could
just strangle you [ __ ] oh my god yeah
I've had some positive experiences with
people so I think I think even though
like you what you say is true and there
are people who are being horrible to
each other and people who are hoarding
toilet paper for no good reason I don't
know why why yes there there have been a
lot more I know there's a lot more
kindness I think in the streets and I
think that sometimes when something like
this happens you do have people like you
know it's almost like they don't sweat
the small stuff anymore so it's so it's
like hey you know like this like
familial beef that I had with you over
whatever like no we're just we're just
worried about everybody being safe you
just want you know mom and dad to be
safe I want our kids to be safe make
sure you got enough food like I'm not
even beefing about that $20 you owe me I
mean let me catch you in August you know
when this pendennis over is gonna be bad
but for now just be safe but you gave me
that 20 spot yeah